[Music]
so the cicadas are back
17 years underground and they have
emerged over huge parts of the eastern
united states
billions of them there are so many
brewed ex cicadas
around that people started eating them
normally we would judge anyone who would
eat a winged
insect but in a moment like this you got
to keep an open mind and we have
brett larson knows a lot about eating
bugs he's from fox news headlines
he's going to walk us through a taste
test of brudex cicadas brett good to see
you
tucker good to be here yeah the the
brood x kind of sounds like the rival
gang at the
at the high school quad but this uh this
is the group of cicadas that show up
every 17 years last time we saw them was
2004.
uh they are notable for that loud
sound that they make it's often heard
when we go to press conferences
throughout the washington dc area when
we're hearing politicians it's almost
hard to hear them 100 decibels is how
loud that sound can get
it's interesting the sound that you are
hearing from the cicadas is actually the
mating call
of the male cicada to the female cicada
to get the groove on
so they can make the babies drop them
back down in the ground and they'll pop
out 17 years later
they are edible and tucker we got you
some edibles
ready for you from the rising creek
bakery in mount morris pa
they sent you quite a variety of
delicious treats there
including cicadas now we have to say
this the fda has said if you have an
allergy to shellfish so shrimp or
lobster crawfish things like that
if you have an allergy to those don't
eat the cicadas you'll have an allergic
reaction to the cicadas because they're
actually in the same
family but they are otherwise safe to
eat as for your
pets it's okay for them to eat them in
moderation if your dog goes out in the
backyard and grabs them
so you are going to try one of these
delicious cookies and and let the world
know i gotta be
pretty tasty i gotta be honest with you
brett my producers left these on my desk
as i was writing my scripts and i never
looked carefully at baked goods and i
already ate one and and i can say
i'm embarrassed to admit that but it's
actually true i shouldn't have but i did
they just looked too good and it was
delicious but they've asked me to eat
one on tv just to reassure
our viewers who are kind of on the fence
about eating bugs who are bug curious as
we say in the bug community
and i'm going to eat it there's just
cake right on the top
um yeah i mean i think you dip honestly
it's delicious you dip something in
chocolate it's not going to be that bad
there i've seen recipes popping up
online from all the celebrity chefs
toss them a little sesame oil throw a
little chopped garlic in there
they're going to be amazing just don't
get any different you know double check
before you're eating other bugs but just
know that the cicadas are safe for now
and actually they're a good
source of protein so all in all and as
you're saying they're they're they're
not that bad so
maybe every 17 years we have some
interesting edibles involving
bugs the only thing that kind of wrecks
it for me is i know that bill gates
approves
so this is the last time cicadas but for
the record there's no microchips in the
cicadas they've been in the ground for
too long
yeah we don't know that brett brett
larson
thanks so much